what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are back for bad batch
season two joined by my friend who you
might have seen on the Jedi Survivor
trailer reaction with me one of the
biggest Star Wars nerds I know but
easily the only individual I know in
real life who is vehemently looking
forward to the bad batch Michael the
Tesla how are you Michael oh I am doing
absolutely magical I'm so excited it's
the bad batch it never gets enough
credit but it's for those of us that
love the Clone Wars I would say Rebels
too because it looks like I love Rebels
connective intermediate threat it's more
than animation style there's just like
something about it that like brings me
back to being single and alone in high
school
um it's a good feeling
it's just like oh well yeah I could I
could try to go out or I can enjoy the
Star Wars content who needs a girlfriend
when you have Dave filoni
like for Dave filoni people come comment
for Pablo Hidalgo subscribe and click
that notification Bell to get notified
when a reaction for the next batches up
also full length and watch along as we
sync up with your own copy of the bad
batch available for our super sexy
Rejects at our patreon page we also
cover several shows over there
exclusively with reaction highlights and
watch alongs included Michael ready to
get the show on the road um
I just wanted to hold my baby I like to
think of the bad batch as the real
rejects of the Star Wars Universe let's
get the show on the road
that starts off on Grievous yeah
I wonder what his corpse is doing at
this point
I think he's still on YouTube
ah yeah
Spoils of War that's nice the Metal Gear
Solid episode
well this looks beautiful yeah right
tired of Life on Coruscant
what are those
[Music]
Omega
it's a tad older yeah
it's got this whole Ezra thing going on
who is that we need a pickup copy that
we're on our way you're gonna kill all
these innocent creatures
God it's very jedi-like the women and
the children
[Music]
what a swashbuckling open up here right
[Music]
oh Moana is way cooler than I remember
she is so much more badass yeah right
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
how do you not love this show it's so
much fun it is a fun show
Crowds Are like you something some
[ __ ]
staying inside the ship next time I'll
try
but it was still pretty fun
yeah this is good it kind of feels like
the jump that Ezra had from season one
the season two Rebels
quite late
they're still at the bar yeah where else
to be the space decided to finally show
up better late than dead I always say
and who are you yeah who are you
wouldn't you like to know yeah I would
actually so
this is the top team you've been talking
about it's like what is
yeah they let everybody in Star Wars now
huh she's a friend she's the most
trustworthy pirate I know because it's
supposed to be comforting aren't clone
supposed to look alike so much for
quality control it feels offensive
this one's got a face tattoo
yeah real subtle
hey now
got a name brown eyes oh however the
phenotypic eye color for all clones is
brown Iris pigmentation was not affected
by it was fascinating God damn technique
just when you had a chance blew it right
away
then action
follow me
uh yes ma'am
hahaha
do you remember the the two sisters from
uh from Clone Wars yeah I wonder if
there's a connection there you were
heading to the outer rim
that is Caso Sereno the former home
Count Dooku yeah
yeah no he was a royal family with him
being dead Dooku's entire War chest is
up for grabs ah cool but there is still
time to strike before it's all gone too
much of a risk
you want that war chest you go after it
Sid spin-off
date of the Empire's radar since kamino
what chance it now
because the contents of just one of
those containers would be worth more
than all the jobs you pulled for me
combined really
we're already free clearly you're not
paying attention to what's happening out
there but I am
time before the Empire comes here
exactly she does have a valid point you
want to really be free and pull off this
Heist and you'll have the means to
disappear the frick out of here no way
to the outer rim
I have a feeling Hunter and Omega will
have some Strife in this season hmm that
feels appropriate but we can do better
things with Dooku's Fortune than hide
Hunter
's looking for money
our lives are like this because of Omega
oh you know was the right thing to do
but there are others out there who need
our help we've seen what the Empire is
doing throughout the Galaxy
we should be doing more I like this Echo
yeah me too and so Serrano is a really
interesting place
it's Count Dooku and his dad had a big
falling out when he left for the Jedi
Order and kind of walked away from his
title and Dooku when he came back was
able to kind of you know live the life
that uh its father had dreamed of for
him but at a cost
[Music]
oh
these artists are not paid enough
what happened to it Imperial orbital
bombardment
same as old Camino
it appears that they are beginning to
transport the wall chest off-world our
window of opportunity is quickly closing
I love the rebels stole some of those in
in Rebels for their little Fleet
I think they could do this
that is a risky ass mission
like at this point who's really even
opposing the empire
there's nobody left
[Music]
It's Gonna Hurt
great shot oh man
the priority is items of high value like
what anything shiny or heavy is a start
retrieve the remaining containers from
the palace stay on schedule oh
foreign
right
look at those credits it's gonna be like
a lightsaber or anything neat from
Dooku's collection I'd say that
qualifies as high value that the
majority of Dooku's Fortune came from
the many worlds he controlled and
exploited those were corrupt people
but
that what we're doing
kids are too smart interesting debate to
be had you could use the diversion about
now on it so Dooku had a lot of Fortune
huh yeah no Dooku's family comes from
money that's how we finance the war
[Music]
originally when he left the Jedi Order
Jedi only really weren't that upset with
him I think probably because they gave
them some money he made some donations
and stuff he was hoping he could still
have a good relationship what caused the
blast unknown Captain all systems went
normal prior to the explosion tried to
pull three secure your cargo and prepare
to launch all scores
I love that they've started to strip
away some of the colors of the Clones to
take away their individuality
[Music]
come on it's a hunter and Records go
through them yeah I was gonna say uh I
love that they're still just stunning
them oh yeah
[Music]
not too hard
oh no we gotta go where
jump
jump oh my God
do it we'll get to the marauder and
recover you uh oh they're about to be
separated yeah that's never a good sign
[Music]
are you sure this hitch will lead into
the ship if I am incorrect we will
instantly be sucked out and perish
I am seldom
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's nice and ostentatious
oh trapdoor elevator
release the Escape pods
man they really want them containers on
classical Freighters are equipped with
re-entry thrusters we can escape in a
cargo container cargo
I love that I love how that container
block yeah
we're getting out of here we're not
going out we're going down aha
oh it's time to be clever
[Music]
go hit it man
here's me on an elevator
yikes
Disney if you're watching this big great
new Tower of Terror
[Music]
Tech is so much cooler than he gets
credit for yeah I agree
oh my God I love this
is going to be a problem all that
fortune
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
ER they didn't did not mince a moment
damn that was cool yeah I'm I'm honestly
so impressed all right guys so we did a
whole review for episode one but then we
realized oh wait there's two episodes
out so we're gonna watch episode two
right now yeah let's get to it
[Music]
wow it's like meteors falling from the
sky we are descending at a rate of speed
that is most concerning don't worry
increase should engage soon if they
don't we're all dead
no [ __ ] Sherlock
Ah that's gotta hurt dick did you reach
the Escape pods yet not exactly we are
using an alternate mode of Transport my
calculations have us crashing towards
the upper Forest region of the planet
crashing
[Laughter]
leave you alone for five minutes
[Music]
thank you for Flying Star Tours
Roger Roger
[Music]
oh
no oh I was kidding when I said kill one
of them
nerd
[Laughter]
so no
because some surprisingly good writing
so far this season
what do you see up there
still haven't landed
uh that's funny that was wonderful like
picturesque shots yeah
it's unlikely the thieves who
infiltrated the cargo ships survived the
crash I want confirmation redirect our
top side forces monitor all calm
channels and bring a shuttle yes sir
Captain Wilkos the [ __ ] huh yeah right
and that's sexy epaulette yeah Yum Yum
Yum we can't leave without the war chest
don't be cocky kid this is the path to
the dark side Omega is it
greed
I wonder if there's any survivors
Jedi Survivor first
something about the aesthetic of
Republic gunships
just does something for me my God
this is
I live here the name's Romar where's the
nearest place to take shelter
well it's a little hard to think with
her pointing that thing at me
well think with it
I'm registering a heat Source 200 meters
west of here
's your domicile how did you take us
there
divide the search and Recovery squads
people containers were released I want
eyes on all 50
copy that we only have 50 soldiers
how many explosives do you have nothing
to do any damage
couple of smoke bombs
smoke bombs for record
oh old separatist tanks now you're
talking he could do a lot of wreckage
look at that you know what I mean ah man
you should quit your day job
he's gonna find a little wooden boy in
there
Pinocchio a Star Wars story Troopers
could already be at the crash site
guess you're more like those other
clones than you think oh I stay away
from that cursed War chest if I were you
a cursed in war Chester he took from us
his own people there's enough in that
container for all of us I want none of
it
let the Empire take it
the sooner they're gone the better and
the same goes for you
damn duker you've done some serious
damage we can still Scout the sight to
see if it's clear negative your mission
is to keep an eye on the old man Roger
you're gonna realize there's a new
Mission at hand Omega involves dealing
with other people this experience is
really going to shape their values
[Music]
thanks for the ride
please music
[Music]
God you're just gonna stand there
no matters I'm keeping an eye on you
not much fun is it
try that
what is it
boy oh it's a kaleidoscope
uh jewels and
no steal it it's an optical illusion
it's not treasure it's a toy
makes you happy and believe me that is
worth more than any Jewel except for an
actual Jewel yeah that's worth way more
money like a home that's not leveled by
Hellfire
this here contains a fragment of my
people's history a separatist archive
fascinating
we did exist before the war you know
I
never thought of it like that racist
I love this like post-world War II like
yeah going to Berlin being like Oh yeah
Germany before they were there were just
Nazis
Germans too we had lederhoses strudel a
lot of culture
that one
forget it wrecker that Tank's not going
anywhere
air support not approach
air support man they really can't take
these two guys down
this kind of looks like the whenever
they cut to the Terminator future
[Laughter]
yes
there goes not killing any clones
shot from the snow
man
I love that one of them is using a stun
gun
[ __ ] up
your data has been restored
you did it you
oh you
saved my people
he was just here
no not his stuff no the old guy stuff
no I think she's going back to the uh I
think she still stalls the old guys
that's joking
like what's wrong
is that her bad batch thing she's a
kleptomaniac yeah is that her unique uh
you won't get very far in your condition
I can manage
foreign
oh my God him and his people are gonna
help oh interesting and maybe they'll
give some of the treasure back
[Music]
yeah this new Indiana Jones movie is
great I woke it up
cool murder murder
yeah the scent of his speeder I'm
scanning another container Dead Ahead
stay alive
oh that was cool a little Order 66 when
they pull back in the
um
yes
good references
LAPD
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh no he's got a broken leg too
the bad legs
look I picked it full of the shiny stuff
laughs
she's now become a precocious little
child
great uh that's like Battlefront 2 right
here
no no no no no take your way through it
[Music]
I don't like this oh what the hell's
going on no you can't kill attack uh
Echo is like the most ungradable one uh
Captain Wilco The Intruders are
retreating to the Eastern Ridge reroute
air support security teach Omega lesson
make Greg like Tech and then kill him
we're in position
those lasers can't take down those trees
I like that trees and video games and
trees and TV shows impenetrable
thank you
oh I could feel that
ah come on come on come on
oh good it's Oscar
can you imagine the off screen on
ceremony is death
I don't feel good about it still
make sure to carry all the [ __ ] oh my
God
oh my gosh oh you gotta make a choice
it's like that scene in The Mummy yeah
it's gonna be a consequence
yes it is
I heard what you said Hunter on the
marauder
you don't have a normal life because of
me
oh no
oh I didn't realize that's why she was
doing all that
oh that is so sad
all right all right
[Music]
ace wake up
I heard Blaster fire
I thought you might need some help I
love him and I was right
[Laughter]
he'd fit right into the bad batch
I'd watch the spin off
I will handle the ship I'll grab the
cable stun the ship
freezes
come on Space Geppetto space pedo no no
no
Speedo
[Laughter]
[Music]
nicely done dude this is tax episode
yeah
[Music]
Ah that's badass
[Music]
all right
all right
is that nice old guy that helps you even
got a flat
oh space pedal you did it
that would be our ride
foreign
[Music]
keep it
what about you I'm a survivor
remember thanks Grandpa Joe
that's how Omega won the Chocolate
Factory
for you Sid
and realize a mega was clocked in there
yeah I can't do it I tried doing a
female one
oh my God what if he reports
bad reports
oh you got a new toy see fun is
everything Greg I wanted to make things
better for us I know you all gave up
everything because of me
good thing we did we might be fighting
for the Empire right now
oh this is so touching we made the right
choice Omega I can't say touching I'd do
it all again
oh they're about to be in trouble you
stated the would-be thieves you
encountered were the Rogue clones from
experimental unit 99 however yet that is
impossible
and their squad perished during the fall
of De poker City
ah they don't realize that's how they've
been free
I had visual confirmation on two of them
they're alive
if Governor Tarkin were to learn of my
misstep then I would be at risk yeah
which is why a new report will be
submitted one void of any mention of
Clone Force 99 that's the difference
between clones and humans
I will not falsify an official report
they are about to die dude
foreign
I bet he's still falling
oh man
Dave falloni
what what uh what an experience
um is that how they're gonna phase out
the Clones by having every one of them
one by one brutally murdered by
somebody's scared of Tarkin
laughs
well well well that was a uh that was a
really good uh second episode yeah I was
it was action-packed uh we got a space
Geppetto uh who I'm glad I really
thought they were gonna kill him off I
hope we see him again hope he gets his
own spin-off yeah I was in Riddell Romar
Romar Romar yeah okay you know what we
should do for YouTube yeah we should
sort of combine what we said oh for both
for both episodes yeah yeah just to make
it a little bit easier easier for you
yeah for me personally actually to me
and and uh so here's uh the thoughts on
the first episode yeah
playing I don't even remember that
nah dude the first episode is um like it
was it was awesome to see Omega come
into her own yeah um I like that like in
Ezra in season one uh of rebels where it
was like oh this is gonna be rough to
have you as a protagonist uh it was
really nice season two you start seeing
that growth change
um and it was really fun to like watch
them grow
through the lens of the rest of the pad
batch yeah um and it was nice I feel
like you know as you're saying during
the episode like there was not a lot of
utilization particularly of tech and
Echo
um and the two of them really stepped up
and and this is what I was hoping for
when I saw the trailer yeah because
um like uh you know Echo especially is
uh the product of the evil that the
Empire has done and I've wanted to see
more
Echo because he would have the most
personal motive to want to help you know
and he kind of took a back seat with the
last season when the introduction of the
bad batch involved rescuing him so I
thought he'd be a more prominent
character if it makes sense for your
first season you want to focus you want
to really flesh out here yeah the new
characters yeah and so I really love
um that Echo is becoming this motivating
force I don't want to do the thing I
said I want to do let's just combine
what we're talking about into one
episode
because yeah I think that what they did
especially with Omega was great as I
didn't understand fully like why she was
so gung-ho and about like getting that
Treasure Chest did you pick up I didn't
pick up yeah well I said it you know
it's like oh that makes a lot of sense
now it's interesting because they've
they've kind of set this stage for what
will be the conflict this season within
the bad batch with there being a sense
of like it's either we run or we fight
and I've had it was interesting to put
Omega in that equation sure and I like
that they kind of set us up and then
they reminded us at the end that Omega
is just a kid and her perspective on
this is coming from such a place of
innocence and a desire to fit in and to
have a family and the the real
ramifications of what the bad batch is
deciding to do is just completely not
even on our radar yeah
um I agree I agree I think it's a great
setup for them as a whole family unit
and I I did I guess I didn't register
that they all that the that people
what's the name of it it's not coming it
was a specific city called Serrano
Sereno in in uh know where they thought
they died it is Camino what's the city
of Kansas
uh what's what's the the
the setup that oh yeah that's right
they're presumed dead right now yeah and
and I think it's it was especially
Crosshair now that they're alive yeah
but it's in crosshairs interest to also
lie in this moment and it actually that
that's it there's a great point where it
does set up has Crosshair
has the Chip And crosshairs brain
crossed hairs and yeah you know are they
beginning to question their allegiance
sure
um because I always kind of wondered how
much of that was the chip and how much
of that was Crosshair seems like it's
mainly him I feel like it the the
at least a part of him
um you know uh it's definitely really
interesting to
see how humans as they enter Imperial
ranks
are like it kind of shows the demise of
the Empire really of like oh well I'm
scared of the consequence of fader forth
Force choking me out in a meeting so I'm
gonna not tell the truth yeah
um yeah that guy's gonna get Force jokes
uh Wilco is great though
um I really I thought that was like a I
was hoping we'd see more of him but I'm
like we thought we're gonna get Cody
yeah well I think that's what's going to
be really fun about Echo this season
right like he is the only character that
I think from the perspective of like
your average clone during the Clone Wars
will be able to really
like the weight of leaving the fight I
think is going to hit him harder than
everybody else
um and also needing to go directly
against the other clones
um you know so it'll it'll be
interesting to see what what happens
um you know I'm I'm curious as to this
kind of setup of this the the new
character what was her name at the at
the top Wanda Sykes
good brain
um you know I wonder if that's going to
be connected to any of our other
you know
um
yeah and it was it was nice that they
they seem aware that you finished that
sentence
it's a great finisher a good button on
that did I wrapped it with a bow what
was the the name of
um oh yeah I wonder if that's going to
be connected um yeah yeah but uh
so I wonder if that's gonna be connected
to anything
[Laughter]
no I I definitely uh as it pertains to
fee I'm curious if if she's gonna be
connected to some Rebel elements or you
know if maybe that's how we're gonna
reconnect to the Galaxy at large in
terms of
you know I mean it's there is no
Rebellion per se at this point like
everything's in its infancy and I feel
like that's a
I'm excited to see what that looks like
you know what was neat was like when we
did the we felt the reaction for the
first episode and we're putting one and
two in the same episode but you were
doing a lot of uh you're pointing out a
lot of like the history of
of um
Serrano no God yeah yeah the Dooku yeah
yeah yeah I remember feet but Dooku is a
hard pool for me
but uh with uh Dooku and and um and then
it was crazy to see how much that
history did factor in so much with this
Romar character yeah and uh explaining
his people and and how and it really is
like he is like a Hitler kind of kid is
it is it was like a citizen in Berlin
after the war who's just like really
struggling yeah to
I mean how do you separate the evil and
the selfishness of an individual from an
entire people you know and uh you know
and you see the reality of it um and at
the end of the day the thing that he was
most concerned about it wasn't the
treasure wasn't the money it was
preserving their culture their past
exactly and their identity separate of
ironically the separatists
um you know so yeah I thought that was
really well done and I thought Serrano
was such an interesting it was an
interesting choice
um because I think something that will
be fun throughout bad batch is to watch
these characters slowly and surely
realize that even when they were in the
Republic that doesn't necessarily mean
they were the good guys yeah
um and I feel like that's such a great
you know I love George Lucas but like
Star Wars very good very evil like
it was it was always very clear who is
what um and something that was really
wonderful about the Clone Wars is it
really explored all the gray and Andor
too and and or especially Andor um
that's a great Point yeah
um yeah so I mean it was a it was a a
great start
um you know I sometimes with the show I
feel like it was made specifically for
Dave filoni like
it's his you know like like he watches
it a couple thousand times to keep the
views and stuff up but like
um but I wish more people watched it and
enjoyed it because I'm beginning to see
the thread between this to the new
Ahsoka series to Andor to Mandalorian oh
what the the one of the show Runners
recently came out and said like no
there's going to be some very clear
connections I mean they already had like
Fenix Shan in the last one oh yeah but
there's gonna be some uh it's gonna be
much clearer the connection to
Mandalorian
um this season so I think omega's
particular cloning existence is gonna be
connected to grogu and a lot of what
because they're more than likely yeah
well the planet that we saw at the end
of of the last season where the Survivor
from Camino was brought
um I mean that's the the cloning
facility were like
it all got started with with grogu and
all that stuff so but damn there's some
good [ __ ] in here yeah I am I'm I do
prefer this show when it's more a
serious and more and darkest personally
like I love all the nighttime sequences
I think they executed the action great
the music is just as exciting as ever
and I did buy like they pulled a gun
punch here and just randomly killed off
Tech you know I was I was actually I
thought mistakes could could be that
high which is a great a great place I
mean I think similar to Rebels
I think they want the show to grow with
the audience you know I mean every time
I I watch
Star Wars animated series you know I I
feel like they give they give us older
fans just enough to like hold on while
the show gets darker and grittier sure
but they do let their audience grow with
them and like I love that that's one of
my favorite parts of Star Wars is that
no matter what your entry point is you
know if a kid's at like nine or ten like
this is epic you know this is a great
way to get into it and I felt that way
with Rebels too where like first season
I was like oh boy this is rough
um you know but by like season end of
season two I was like
this is a show for me too and
um the only one I haven't felt that way
about was resistance and I think they
wanted it that way yeah
um I also just couldn't get past that
animation
um which like speaking of I I just like
I feel like they've hit their stride
like this is stunning animation and
they've upgraded I mean I I felt like
last season the first and last two
episodes were were at its prime like it
feels like they really threw down for
their first and last couple and then
this one for the first two at least
because the last season they had a like
a really long Premiere didn't they it
was like a 40-minute episode yeah it was
a they did exactly the same thing here
yeah we're gonna put in two episodes
instead I still I still have not
recovered from them not doing anything
with Freddie Prince Junior's voice
that's young Kane and jarus as like why
is there a grown man speaking in this 12
year old
uh but you know but I I thought the you
know the darker they get the better the
series is yeah I mean just like watching
Caminos think was just like well even
like that menacing ending that they had
here
it was uh like I I love that tone a lot
and I love like this sneak and I think
they do a great job with their
perspectives and their shots uh it's
it's really well calculated so yeah yeah
it's it's a I think my biggest
compliment to them is there's such nice
subtle homages to both prior Star Wars
films but other just like really gritty
like there was a few uh moments in there
where the soundtrack and the shots lined
up with like Children of Men which I was
like like what the hell are Star Wars
animators doing like using children of
men as their storyboard
um but like it works and I think it's
Star Wars at its best yeah so
all right well we had a really good
premiere
thank you Michael for being here and
bringing all the Star Wars knowledge oh
of course can't wait to sit here with
you 14 more times 14 times oh they like
me they really like me and and thank you
for all the fan mail that I got uh that
was so sweet of you guys I'm glad you
liked my yoda voice
I liked my voice didn't you yeah let's
not oh let's not do that overdo it you
know all right
Jack Sparrow was Charming the first
three times then it started to get old
you know yeah well that's what my mom
said about me
all right guys May the force be with you
and the force me to leave a like
foreign